but first Licensed to Kill that's the
focus of tonight's
Angle now growing up as a kid in the 70s
there were plenty of changes happening
in society there was the withdrawal from
Vietnam there was Nixon resigning the
gas lines oh I remember those and the
Jimmy Carter
malays but with all of that I don't
remember ever hearing about stories of
mobs mostly young people brazenly
committing criminal acts and I'll tell
you the Christmas season we all know
it's right around the corner you're
already hearing the Christmas music
everywhere and it means that more FedEx
deliveries we're going to see them all
over but now truck drivers aren't just
worried about getting packages there on
time a blitz robbery of a FedEx delivery
truck the driver described the heist in
detail telling Memphis Police multiple
cars blocked him off at the red light on
the corner of West mallerie Avenue and
Riverport Road in South Memphis around
8:30 Saturday night then they broke into
his truck and stole $100,000 worth of
other people's deliveries leaving behind
empty boxes and putting our city further
on edge of course no one arrested so far
and that lack of consequences is what
has propelled other Rampages Nationwide
Chicago has seen its fair
share
[Applause]
and earlier this fall a 100 or so thugs
rans sack stores in
Philadelphia the CCTV footage of how
casually they ended up getting into this
Pharmacy smashing everything taking
every everything they could it's
chilling and it's a Sayo say same Mo
every time everyone in a mask or a
hoodie or a hat and because remember
after 2020 it's totally normal for
people to wear surgical masks and rubber
gloves in public they just do that in
total as of today over 70 arrests have
been made there here are some of the mug
shots now the accused are mostly in
their 20s and 30s most are minorities
mainly
African-American then in Vegas a
horrific attack caught on video Jonathan
Lewis age 17 was beaten by a mob at his
school now as you see we're blurring the
faces because most most of these
attackers are minors the victim here was
white the attackers appear to be black
of course most of the media ignoring
that information because crime is crime
no matter who's committing it
obviously but when you have a media
that's desperately trying to help pull
Joe Biden across the Finish Line in 20
24 and that doesn't want to admit that
we have a major crime problem in this
country you soon learn that the Press
takes every potential story about crime
and turns it into a story about race so
ask yourself why does race get
prominently mentioned when the criminal
is white and the victim is black we're
kicking things off with what the folks
are calling bloody Saturday and the
Alabama sweet tea party that's right I
am talking about the Alabama brawl that
took place after two white men attacked
a black Alabama boat captain video
showed a group of white men attacking
him before it escalated into a bigger
fight but it turn out that racism was
not a motivating factor in that fight at
all Jim catrell the captain of the
Harriet 2 told The Daily Beast that he
thought race might have been a factor in
the initial attack on his co- Captain
but the resulting melee was not a black
and white
thing now the media's first instinct is
always to ignore the race of the
criminals unless white people are the
perpetrators remember that one of
Biden's themes for 2024 one of his main
themes throughout his entire
Administration is that white people in
the United States are fundamentally of a
racist and evil history so the media are
seeking every opportunity to promote
that message this is why black-on-black
crime the majority of both violent
criminals and their victims in the
United States are black and black women
are especially hard- hit that story is
largely ignored but black women account
for 25% of Crime Victims in most
categories and again mostly ignored by
the Press kudos for CBS for doing that
report and in New Orleans black people
make up the majority of murder victims
but look it's not just in those two PL
going back for decades liberal
sociologists have posited that the
disproportionate violence committed by
black men is linked to the violence that
had been perpetrated against them during
the slave period now this idea is
nothing new the that the past the unfair
treatment of people in the past just Jus
ifies or explains future bad behavior in
other words victimhood pays but the
problem is as the great Walter Williams
once argued the world is full of victims
we were to sit down and
decide who which people have been fac
you the most destruction the most
oppression in the world I couldn't come
up with a name I mean you know the the
uh Turks tried to exterminate the
Armenians uh the uh the Nazis with the
Jews the uh the uh uh uh the Irish and
the Catholic the Hugo I mean they
persecuted people I mean it's nothing
unique about blacks if you went to look
at history and decide who was persecuted
most it's a useless
battle but in their desperate efforts to
smear America as a fundamentally racist
and evil country our leaders have
created a generation that believes it
has a license to vandalize steal beat
and sometimes even kill their home life
the popular culture even schools are
teaching them toxic depressing lessons
about race and the American
Experience now the Floyd riots that they
taught them that burning and looting if
done in large enough numbers will go
unpunished cite an underlying racial
grievance and maybe you can expect
leniency as long as you can claim to
hate America the media and the Democrats
will generally back you
up this neo-marxist Dynamic has done
huge damage to race relations in the
United States and also to minority and
workingclass communities of all
backgrounds who are already struggling
to make ends meet somebody's going to
end up getting killed an innocent
bystander you have so
many people that are good citizens that
are carrying guns because they're afraid
of this stuff coming to their doors is
out here in the
streets but remember the Biden
Administration and its supporters in the
Press don't actually care about what
best for minorities or what's best for
any Americans for that matter they care
about one thing winning reelection and
staying in power and that's not easy to
do when crime is such a problem so they
plan to solve that problem not by
stopping crime but by blaming America so
they'll smear the founders they'll smear
Republicans the police anyone they can
think of and the hopes of scaring folks
into voting for Biden they certainly
don't want minority communities to be
confident and prosperous they want them
so scared that they'll vote for Biden
rather than voting for peace and
prosperity
safety so we have to keep reaching out
and telling the truth about America
about crime until that message breaks
through and once we have no leadership
we can once new leadership we can once
again teach the ancient lesson that
crime does not pay and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else